wie zu hause schnell kapiert lebten von
leistungssportlerin beim bundesheer den
halt in klagenfurt und konnte als agent
und offizieren kennen nennen
also müssen wir jetzt auf der truppen
ersten ambulanz für mich aber dann auf
den 20 sie haben die möglichkeit der
behandlung und versorgung von ambulanten
und stationären patienten und die schau
montiert dann
spezialisten vom typ der im zuge einer
übung die heute nachmittag stattfindet
an patienten vorbereitet der
fußverletzung simuliert und schaue mir
an
luk
was man jetzt gehen haben war eine übung
der sieger patrick es ist ein feuerkorb
kommen und zum auskommen eine soldaten
angeschossen worden ist
faktoren ist in dieser folge dann vom
band gefahren bin
anfangs ist es ist der letzte woche
vorher genau das ist der verletzte der
vorbereitete übung
wir in der rettungssanitäter aus das
heißt grund berliner und kadersoldaten
und wir können die ausbildung zum
sanitäter bei uns anbieten
die überlegungen
wie sie zum beispiel mit dem krankenhaus
oder bei öffentlichen rettungsdienst ich
glaube dass die möglichkeiten die
ausführungen seien könne sie einfach
viel größer ist für vielfältiger und was
wollen die fasziniert hat war die
möglichkeit ins ausland zu gehen
ich habe aber insgesamt 25 monate im
auslandseinsatz und dort eben das
umsetzen können was sie in der theorie
in der praxis durch meine ausbildung
lernen hat dürfen
du hast mir vorhin erklärt das kloster
waren bislang ist es auch möglich glaubt
mama zu sein ist immer herausforderung
natürlich genauso hat beim bundesrat in
eine von vielen soldatinnen die
mittlerweile schon mama geworden sind
und ich muss dazu sagen dass das
bundesheer ganz gute möglichkeiten
bietet das heißt mit teilzeit mit
gleitzeit dass man das hat
dementsprechend an um damit im zuge
unserer ausbildung in der kompanie haben
natürlich nicht nur theoretischen von
einer praktischen unterricht in dem fall
hat bei der sie bei unserer übung mit
dem verunfallten fahrzeug zur ausbildung
zum qualität und offizier aus
letztendlich gewinnt das ganze mit der
ausbildung zum rettungssanitäter neben
den militärischen laufbahn kurven dann
die ausbildung zum notfallsanitäter mit
lothar kompetenzen
das heißt wie sieht die möglichkeit für
anerkannte kurse durchgeführt werden
dementsprechend als berufsausbildung im
zielraum